hello everyone
i am isaac chamie part of the nathan
lewis lab at uc san diego
in my fifth year of my ph mathematics
and systems biology
i wanted to first thank everyone for
coming to my talk
and the bio processing event for
extending an invitation
for me to speak here today i'm going to
be talking about one exciting study that
i worked on
which is a chinese hamster transcription
start site atlas that enables targeting
editing of cho cells
and just to note this report is in
bioarchive at the moment and is under
review
at nar genomics so keep your eyes out
for that in the next few months
and the relevant data is on synapse and
geo and if anyone is
interested you can reach out to me and
i'd be happy to provide that information
okay so let's get started with some
background and motivation on the study
and i'm sure most of you here are
familiar with the rise of
biopharmaceuticals in the drug market
along with the fact that chinese hamster
ovary cells or cho cells
are the biopharmaceutical workhorse
producing many of these top selling
drugs
and importantly with that cho cells
being this workhorse we have
for decades tried to optimize the
processing that goes on in these
cho cells to improve various phenotypes
of these biopharmaceuticals
and we did that with multiple approaches
over the decades that include bioprocess
optimization
targeting engineering and more recently
system characterization
which includes a lot more of high
throughput omics
studies and wide scale genome screens
to try to understand the function of
certain genes that may contribute to
desired phenotypes
and our lab more recently has been
interested
in understanding functional screens to
unders to uncover novel
genes that are important for certain
phenotypes these phenotypes
include various things like productivity
apoptosis glycosylation
modifying the glycosylation profile of
certain recombinant proteins that we
care about and the secretion rates as
well
and additionally one method that has
been used pretty often
in mammalian space which hasn't been as
adapted yet
to the cho space in general specifically
is crispr screens in which we design
guide rnas
that target each gene and we try to
insert those guide rnas such that
they're infecting only one cell
and we can then screen for certain
desired phenotypes such as secretion
glycosylation profiles or productivity
and then we can u
with that information we can see which
genes are actually functional
for these types of uh phenotypes that we
care about
and one recent method that we care about
as well that we've been looking at
oh and one more thing for this is that
it requires the knowledge
of these genomic parts it requires the
knowledge of
the genes themselves and accurate
descriptions of them
and so one more thing on these crispr
screens is that we are interested
in crispr activation and inhibition
screens in which instead of double
stranded guide rna breakage which typ
the original crispr was developed for
these actually can activate or inhibit
our the gene expression itself by
recruiting or inhibiting
um transcriptional elements that just
upstream of the transcription start
sites
which is something that we are going to
be talking about in length
uh for this talk and one more
part of to just hone in on these
transcription start sites and their
relevance for crispr
is that in a previous 2014 study in
humans
they uh gilbert adolf found that when
designing guide rnas multiple of them
across varying regions relative to the
tss
they were able to find that that
guide rnas that are right nearby within
150 base pairs of these transcription
start sites
actually are the most effective in
extrapolating out the desired phenotype
that they want
here being rice and phenotype and
responding to rice and the toxin rice
so now we want to know okay great can we
do this
in cho and so previous work in our lab
have kind of failed at getting that to
work for crispr activation at least
and importantly we did a 2018
reference genome assembly of the chinese
hamster which included more long reads
and we were able to resolve
a lot of regions that were missing in
the promoter regions of
the prior annotation and so in this
figure here you can see that
the red refseq bar the red is where
they map these uh our guide rnas or our
old
our new genes are mapping to where the
refseq is and we can see that this red
one
is completely missing in the refseq
annotation the one completely upstream
and so we realized that there was a lot
of missing
aspects to the prior annotations
now with that study we there's still
some problems with getting the
transcription start site specifically
and annotations in general in certain
understudied species
are built on computational homology
modeling
and usually some rna-seq data but as
i'll show you in the
in slides rna-seq data isn't really
great for capturing transcription start
site
information and there is no
experimental sequencing data targeting
the transcription start sites
in the chinese hamster ovary itself and
so we thought this would be great
opportunity for us to really map out the
parts of
the tss uh regions such that this could
help enable
further studies into crispr or you know
motif element studies and many other
aspects so we decided let's try to build
this
transcription start site map and so
there were a few goals
that we wanted to take into account when
doing this we wanted to use start site
specific next generation sequencing
to enumerate the gene transcription
start sites in high quantity we wanted
to make sure that we were mapping out
many of them
additionally we wanted to make sure they
had good quality we wanted to make sure
that we were actually getting the real
transcription start sites
and last we really wanted to validate
the utility of having these tss
using crispr a to activate the silence
gene mgat3 which is typically silence
and chell
okay so i'm going to give for those who
most of you i'm sure may not be so
familiar
with the ngs tss techniques
and so i'm just going to give a brief
overview to give you an idea of what the
methods that we are using
it's going to be a bit basic but
essentially we have
two different methods global run on
nuclear sequencing with cap
and cap small rna-seq so both of these
experiments
enrich for the five-prime cap that is
their main goal so as you can see
an mrna transcript before it's spliced
has the five prime cap the in
exons introns and the poly a tail and
our methods are going to enrich for
these caps
and so a dish they enrich for the five
prime
another part that something i'll be
talking about later on is that they both
pick up enhancer rna
which is not the full scope of our talk
but it's really interesting where
enhancer rna essentially
is enhancer regions transcribed into rna
but are degraded
very rapidly and so many rna-seq
techniques
cannot actually pick that up however
these techniques that we have which are
basically like nascent rna capturing can
actually pick up these enhancer
rna which allows us to do further
studies on enhancers
with these techniques as well something
that cage chic and other
cap cap analysis can't do as well
there are other aspects of cage seek
that are problematic for
our purposes but just know these are the
two studies these are the two methods
that we use
and just a little bit more about the
differences
growcap essentially you're measuring the
nascent rna
as it's being transcribed off as the as
the
rna is being transcribed directly off
and it requires nuclear extraction
versus cap small rna
is extracting small rnas and essentially
is a proxy for nascent rna
and additionally it makes it much easier
to capture certain difficult tissues
that aren't that easy to capture with
groscap
which is another reason why we wanted to
use this csrna
now an important aspect additionally is
to have a control a background
and so these backgrounds each study how
each method has its own background
which for grow crap would be grow and
for csrna would be the
small rna or csrna input and essentially
the important thing to know is that
these are rnas
that cover that aren't exactly nascent
and they'll cover
other areas of the rna region and we can
use this to make sure that our tss are
enriched over the background
okay and so just a little bit more
on the on the cap small but for the sake
of time i won't go into too much detail
on it
you can read up about it and dick at all
2019
but essentially just to show on the
bottom panel
when we have our csr and a seek we have
our input
and then we run our bioinformatics
pipeline to do tss calling
to make sure that these are encryption
start size
we then do some later filtering
processes which can be
found in our paper which to make sure
that we're calling our tss and we're
calling them as a
annotated uh tss from the ncbi
annotation whether it's related to the
gene and how far away
is it from the from the gene okay with
that all that information
i want to orient you to the actual
results and the data that we have
and so first to show the data that we
actually collect
collected and so we really as i said we
cared about quantity
and an important aspect of that is
making sure that we had a variety of
tissues because we knew
that in cho cho cells we've seen
previous studies that show
under 50 of the genome of the
transcriptome excuse me
is expressed and so that showing us if
we're just going to sequence the chinese
hamsters we're going to get a lot of
site we're not going to pick up a lot of
these tss and so we decided to pick up
bone marrow derived macrophages
and many tissues including brain kidney
liver
lung and a few others and so we also
decided to pick up ataxic which is of a
measure of open chromatin
and rnac total rna-seq which is another
way to
kind of establish the differences um
between
what if the tss are found near rna
regions
or if they're sensors and so
with this variety of data sources and
big data we needed to integrate them
and importantly let me give you an
example of what some of the data looks
like
and to kind of also highlight that the
importance of needing this tss data and
so here is a widely used promoter
widely used gene eef1a1 and from here
you can see that with the rna seq data
you cannot
you do not get the reads that align to
the actual transcription start site
and it just actually fails downstream
versus
when you see these five grow these five
prime cap techniques
with cho or brain or the lung we're able
to see these tss captured actually
upstream of this of this gene and so
this is just to highlight that the
importance of these tss methods in
capturing the tss
now we wanted to see with this
collection how many genes are we
actually capturing we
there's going to um and so what we're
able to see
is that with cho the number of genes is
just under 10
000 and with as we can
incrementally add different tissues
we're able to capture
more and more genes with this which
given us confidence that
increasing the number of tissues was
really useful in capturing these genes
additionally on the right when we're
looking at the ncbi annotation
and we're looking at if the genes are
cho-specific tissue specific or both
we find 9652
are overlapped between cho and the
tissues 198 are cho specific
5 458 are from the tissues themselves
and we weren't able to capture an
additional 6079.
so we had 15 302 genes that were able to
capture
tss for in total now just for some
qc that we wanted to see was to compare
the different methods
and make sure that they gave pretty
similar results and so
when looking at the cho caps
uh csrna and the grow cap i apologize it
seems like the figures are a bit tiny
but
the messaging isn't is clear here where
so
on the top left we see what we did was
we took one experiment
we called their peaks their tss and then
we took
the other experiments whether it was
grow cap or grow cap replicate or the
csrna
and we overlaid the reeds on top of
those peaks
and you could see sharp uh concordance
between the two
then we looked at okay how many of these
peaks actually
overlapped how many number of peaks that
we're capturing are overlapping
which again of which is on the top right
and so we have the csrna and two growcap
replicates
and you could see large overlap between
those as well
and the last part we did was looking at
the counts per million
so the actual number the for each tss
how many reads are we actually seeing
there
and we saw again pretty good correlation
whether it was between
csrna and the grow cap replicate on the
left which was
r of 0.88 or on the right we had a 0.96
between the two grow cap replicas
okay now with this we really wanted to
see
do we have good quality of our tss and
this was one of the results that we were
pretty excited to see and so what we
were
doing here is we were thinking okay how
do we exactly show that these are
better quality and one thing we realize
is okay let's
use a more well-studied organism such as
humans or mouse that may have more
that will have pretty similar promoter
elements it's known that mammalians in
general share promoter elements
in these tss and so we looked at some
canonical
um canonical promoter information
such as nucleotide frequency and
the motif elements certain canonical
motif elements
which include the initiator element
which is typically found around 0
plus 1 base pairs from the tss and the
tata box which is about 28 base pairs
downstream
and so when you see the human you can
tell you can see in these nucleotide
frequency plots
that there's an enrichment of the t and
the a
around 28 base pairs upstream and you
see these initiator
elements as well right around the plus
one and that is corroborated
by motif scanning using the meme suite
now
when we look at our old hamster refseq
the ncbi annotation
this signal is pretty much drowned out
and you don't get to see these canonical
elements when you're out when you're
looking across these annotated genes now
when we look back when we take our
revised annotation
this signal is clearly seen once again
and we see the tata box elements
we see the initiator and we get to see
the nucleotide frequency plot
that looks very similar to the human one
and that gave us good confidence that
our tss were
of high quality as well so with that
information we wanted to look at a bit
of
some data on the tissue diversity itself
we wanted to see where these tss were
which tissues were they coming from
and were they ones that were more common
or less common
and so on the left we see when we parse
out each tss and we
associate it with the gene now and we
see how many tissues are those expressed
in
we actually see that a good amount of
the genes are expressed in all the our
all our samples that we tested and
showing that a lot of these genes are
actually housekeeping genes based on our
tss data
however when you look into the middle
you could still see
that there are some unique tissues and
the unique genes and
tss those are the pink ones which are
found in only
one tissue and so what the middle is
showing
is for each of these the genes that we
have found
in each tissue how many other tissues
is that tss expressed in and so again
what we were looking at right now
is what about the unique ones the little
pink ones that although there were few
ones what information did those tell us
and we did a tissue specific enrichment
analysis
on those tissue specific genes and
interestingly we found
that when using these uh when doing this
test
we found that the unique tss that we
found
in our samples in our specific samples
such as brain kidney liver
lung they were enriched for the
g tissue specific genes
albeit this is from human uh enrichment
database
but we used the homologs for them we
were able to find that they were
enriched for the tissue we would expect
which included
brain for brain kidney for kidney etc
interestingly
just to know is that cho cells did not
actually was not enriched for the ovary
tsea
which is actually corroborating some of
the thought that cho
cells may actually have been derived
from fibroblasts and not actually ovary
cells
that's something that's interesting but
we didn't look any any further on that
information
and so just to talk a little bit more on
these tissues and
some of the new aspects that you can do
now that you have these information
is you can look at motif analysis with
certain promoters that you care about
and what we did here was we just looked
at
the motifs that are enriched in the
tissue specific
promoters and we were able to find again
that there were many
motifs that are specific to one or just
a few
tissues and these were ones that we also
would have expected as well so what you
could see here is
the on the ro each column is a sample is
would be the sample that we had
and each row is the transcription factor
motifs and the
values are their enrichment values uh
which are the p values here
and we did this again instead of just
only on the tissues we did this actually
across
all the common uh all the tss that we
found
and we did an analysis on that and we
found some canonical motifs that we
would expect including sb2
and the ets1 motif and this is really
nice in that
it just allows people to do certain
motifs analysis
if they wanted to use our tss
now importantly we wanted to see if
these new tss can have some utility in
genetic engineering
specifically can we use these to design
certain short guide rna constructs
to be used for crispr activation and so
one of the processes our lab cares about
is glycosylation
as many of you may know as well
glycosylation is very important
in cho engineering to get desired
glycosylation profiles such that it
won't
induce any adverse response
in humans and so we looked at certain
glycoglycan biosynthetic genes to
look at to understand um how many of
these tss were we able to capture
that may be desirable down the line and
so
in blue are the ones expressed in cho
and in red are additional genes that we
captured
by including the tissue information as
what by including the tissue samples
as well and so we could see that a lot
of these
enzymes we're actually able to recover
tss for which will be very useful
moving forward and so we actually wanted
to work on
one specific enzyme which is mgat three
and this was done by our collaborator in
denmark yulia
korkorowski doctor yulia le corcorocci
and we were working on
studying this enzyme mgat3 which adds a
bisecting glucknack
to the glycosylation profile to the
mannose in the middle
and it is silence in show typically and
it is important because it's actually
active in humans
and there may be a desire to activate
this gene and have a functional
copy of mgat3 now when looking at our
tss versus the refseq tsf we noticed
that we had one that was actually 25
kilobases upstream
of where the initial ncbi annotated mgat
3
what tss was and so we decided this
would be a good target
for our analysis
and so when designing we designed three
different guide rnas
relative upstream of that tss and we
found that for all of them we were
actually able to induce a full change of
rna expression which is seen
on the bottom left panel d and it was
really nice and then on top of that what
we did was look to see if there was any
functional activation
of this protein to see if there was any
of the
glucknack that we were able to see and
interestingly
when we compared our data which is the
new tss all the way on the right
to the middle which is the old published
data set by dr karaoke
using the refseq annotation we're
actually able to see an increase in the
percent
of total glycan of the which is
specifically the gluck knack
that we were really cool and it shows
that the utility
of our guide rna in activating
uh a functional working copy of mgat3
and so just to give a little more
information on the details of
this uh our tss and comparing it to some
of the old
data so when we looked and stag stacked
our
reads on top of the old ref ctss we
actually noticed a pretty nice
shift uh that may or m that is
almost consistent it's not consistent
all the time but it's really interesting
to see this shift that
is happening that's offset from the ncbi
refseq
now here on the right is when we looked
at the distribution of how
far the absolute distance of our tss
from the prior annotation and this goes
into the hundreds of base pairs we cap
it off at a thousand here
but you could already see that there are
many of them while some of them are
still centered right nearby some of them
are zero a lot of them are within
10 20 base pairs many of them are
actually shifted and a few hundred base
pairs
uh apart and so with that we were really
happy with this tss
annotation that we have but on top of
that i just want to talk
for a slide just on some of the
additional benefits that this
tss data set that we have can provide
and as i mentioned earlier we can have
enhancer rnas
which show which we call in this paper
distal transcription start sites because
it's not validated that they're
enhancers
but when we take a known sp1 enhancer
and in cho cells and we look at the data
we can see that our nascent rna-seq is
once again
picking up these these values and
we are able to call tss in enhancer
regions
and so we also provide that with
our data and as you can see here so
you'll
be able to see what the enhancer regions
where they are located and where the
nearby gene is
and as you can see here we get that's
where a lot of the diversity and benefit
as well of adding tissues comes even
more
where we get 170 000 that are unique to
the tissues and not unique to cho
19 000 of them that overlap and this is
pretty consistent with
prior studies that looked at this
nascent rna in mammalian studies
and so if people are interested in
studying some epigenetic information
they could also utilize this data set
which can also be
used for promoter for motif element
understanding and a host of other
studies that people can
come up with and so just to bring in
some of the conclusions to wrap this up
we were able to show that the
experimental transcription start sites
across
multiple samples increase the quantity
and the quality
of transcription starts at resolution in
the chinese hamster
additionally we updated our updated
annotation
highlights the similarity to human
promoter elements which is
validating some of the quality of our
tss and
importantly our new tss suggests utility
for
its utility in crispr a experiment and
potentially any other crispr experiments
that people are interested in
that uses this transcription start site
information
and with that i want to thank everyone
thank you so much for this talk and i'd
be happy to
take any questions